in this video we're going to talk about
spectroscopy which is all about the
interactions between light and matter
and when we're talking about light we're
not just talking about visible light
we're talking about electromagnetic
radiation in a general
and so what i'm going to do to give us
an intuition here is use the phet
simulator by the university of colorado
i encourage you to go to this url and
try it out for yourself but you can see
what the simulator does is it allows us
to essentially see how different
wavelengths of electromagnetic radiation
can interact with matter in this case
various molecules and just to get our
bearings we can click on this light
spectrum diagram and we can see that on
this diagram what people would normally
consider radio waves these are some of
the lowest frequencies and longest
wavelengths of light and then when you
get to higher frequencies you get to
microwave and the higher the frequency
that's also the higher the energy per
photon and then you get higher
frequencies than that and higher energy
that's infrared and then higher
frequency and energy than that that's
visible light that's what our eyes can
sense and then you get even higher
frequency and more energy you get to
ultraviolet then x-ray and then gamma
rays and this isn't a linear scale you
can see that this is a logarithmic scale
here this is in powers of 10. so we see
some pretty dramatic increases in
frequency and energy as we go from the
left to the right
but in this video we're going to focus
in particular on microwave infrared
visible and ultraviolet wavelengths of
electromagnetic light or electromagnetic
waves and think about how they interact
with molecules
so if we start with microwave radiation
and here we have a water molecule i've
picked that right over there and i can
get my simulation going
you can see what it's doing is when it
gets absorbed
it causes a rotational transition in the
water molecule it makes the water
molecule rotate in a different way than
it was before and then the water
molecule can also emit the radiation and
then rotate differently and so you can
see it doesn't always do that there's a
little bit of probability involved but
this is actually the basis of how
microwaves work your microwave oven is
it causes the water molecules to get
agitated in a rotational way which
increases the heat in that system
now we could also look at infrared light
which is once again we have to remember
gets us into higher frequencies and see
what that does to molecules
so based on this simulation it looks
like the infrared light is when it gets
absorbed it causes this water molecule
to start to vibrate so microwave
radiation caused it to rotate or to have
a change in state of its rotation while
infrared makes it vibrate and we can see
that with other molecules as well let's
say let's try carbon monoxide
once again it's not rotating it it's
causing it to vibrate
now what about visible light well
visible light will have different
interactions with different types of
molecules but let's try it out with
nitrogen dioxide
so there's certain situations where
nitrogen dioxide will absorb that's when
you saw it glowing and what you see when
it's glowing what it's really doing is
it's putting electrons into a higher
energy state or into a higher orbital
and then when it stops glowing it means
that those electrons are going back to a
lower energy state they are re-emitting
radiation
so there you can see it you can see that
just now it's re-emitting visible light
in this case a different direction and
when it did that the electron that was
excited went to a lower energy state now
what about
let's think about ultraviolet light
which has even higher energy than
visible light what can that do
well here we can see that it takes in
certain cases electrons and it's able to
excite them so much that it's able to
break that bond itself and so let me
keep resetting it so you can actually
break bonds let's see what it can do to
some ozone same thing it excites it so
much that it can actually break the bond
it's exciting an electron so much i can
keep resetting it so the big picture
here the big takeaway you could have
microwave radiation which tends to
change the rotational motion of a
molecule we saw that with the water
molecules
you have infrared radiation which is
higher energy and higher frequency which
tends to lead to a change in vibrational
motion
and then you have visible light which
can excite electrons take them to a
higher energy state and then be
readmitted when the electron goes back
to its base state and then you can have
ultraviolet light that's so powerful it
can excite electrons so that in some
cases it can even break covalent bonds